Imagine we listed all
integers in a growing spiral
and colored the
prime numbers blue
and left the composite
numbers black.
One interesting
question we may ask
is how many primes are there
compared to composites?
First, let's zoom out
to see the big picture.
Notice the prime color is
dense in the center and slowly
drops off in the distance,
but never seems to end.
One way I like to think
about this is as follows.
Imagine there is a tree
at the center, which
is infinitely high.
The leaves which
drop from this tree
represent prime numbers, which
are scattered unpredictably
below, dense near
the base of the tree.
And as we walk away
from this tree,
we find fewer leaves,
though we always find them.
This is exactly
what happens when
we look at larger
and larger integers.
We always find more primes,
though the number of primes
we find gradually drops
the further we look.
So let's return to our question.
How many primes are there
less than some integer x?
If we make a table, we
see the number of primes
is always increasing.
though as we search further,
we find fewer and fewer.
Let's graph the number of primes
found on the vertical axis
and the search size
x on the horizontal.
As we zoom out to include
billions of numbers,
notice the curve
never flatlines.
It's always rising,
albeit gradually.
First, let's think about
the density of primes
less than some integer x.
We can find the
density by dividing
the number of primes
found by the search size.
For the first 100 integers,
we find 25 primes.
Therefore, 25% are prime.
Of the first 10,000 integers,
we find 1,229 primes.
12.29% are prime.
Of the first 1 million
integers, 7.84% are prime.
And the first 100 million
integers contain 5.76% prime.
As we search further, this
density continues to drop,
though the speed at which
it drops slows down.
Here is a graph of the search
size on the horizontal axis
and the prime density
on the vertical.
Notice that as we
zoom out, the primes
are a vanishing proportion
of all integers.
Amazingly, we find
this formula in nature.
We see it in galaxies,
storms, flowers,
and even inside our bodies as
the design of least resistance,
known as the logarithmic spiral.
Notice that as the
spiral rotates,
it gets further and further
away from the center.
Incredibly, the rotation
rate of a logarithmic spiral
is related to the density
of primes as follows.
We have the number of rotations.
Call this phi.
And the distance from
the center, call this r.
If we graph phi
against r and zoom out,
we see they are
related according
to the natural logarithm.
This means the natural
logarithm of the distance
is related to the
number of rotations.
The graph of the
natural logarithm
is commonly written using
the variable names y and x,
as y equals the
natural logarithm of x.
Notice the graph tapers
off in the same way
the density of primes
gradually decreases.
The final step is to invert
this by changing the y-axis to 1
divided by the natural
logarithm of x.
And when we zoom out, we find
the exact same curve generated
when we plot the
density of primes.
Let's confirm this by
overlapping the two plots.
In green is a graph
of the line y equals 1
over the natural logarithm of x.
And in red is the plot of
prime number density up to x.
As we zoom out, they
approach each other.
The further we zoom
out, the more accurate
the green estimate becomes.
This is known as
the asymptotic law
of distribution
of prime numbers.
We now have a formula
to accurately tell us
the density of primes
without counting.
The density of primes up to some
integer x is approximately 1
divided by the natural
logarithm of x, or ln(x).
So let's say you need to
know the density of primes
between one and 100 trillion.
Simple.
1 divided by ln of 100
trillion equals 3.1%.
Compare this to
the actual result
from counting all
primes, which is 3.2%.
This is off by 0.1%, and as
we check larger and larger
numbers, the difference
approaches 0.
Realize now that we can use
this formula for prime density
to estimate the number
of primes up to x.
The number of primes is the
area under the density curve
for which we can simplify by
assuming density is constant.
So number of primes
equals size times density,
or x divided by ln(x).
This is the prime
number theorem.
Here is a graph of y equals
x divided by ln(x) in blue.
And in yellow is a plot of
an actual count of primes.
Notice as we zoom out,
these lines eventually
overlap as we look to infinity.
And that is it.
We have a formula which tells
us approximately how many primes
there are up to any
value, no counting needed.
For example, let's
say we need to know
the number of primes
less than 100 trillion.
100 trillion divided by the
natural log of 100 trillion
equals 3.1 trillion.
Compare this to the actual
count, which is 3.2 trillion.
This is over 99.99%
accurate, even
at this relatively small scale.
So to recap, given a search
size up to some integer x,
the prime density is
about 1 divided by ln(x).
And the number of primes is
about x divided by ln(x).
This is the prime
number theorem.